In today's video,
we are taking a pile
of Himalayan salt lamps,
and putting them through
some stress test
to see just what they can
and cannot handle.
[Music]
Guys, ironically enough,
just a few hours ago today,
Veritasium released
a video that debunked
whether or not Himalayan
salt crystal lamps were
actually good for you,
and released enough negative
ions into the atmosphere
to actually boost your mood.
However, we still have
a bunch of salt lamps.
So, we are going
to be putting these
through a few tests to see just
what they can
and cannot survive.
Here's the basic idea.
We have three salt lamps,
and we are going
to see just what sort
of stress test they can handle.
This is going to
involve water, heat,
and maybe a few other things.
So as far as these
lamps are concerned,
it has been debunked
that they can't really release
that many negative ions to make
a positive impact on moods
or anything like that.
However, there are
types of crystals
that have been proven
to basically boost your mood
because of the way they
release negative ions.
One of those is tourmaline.
Now, that is much more expensive
than Himalayan salt,
which is probably one
of the reasons why
these are much more
commercially available.
That said, we just sort of want
to put them to the test,
and see what else they can do.
All right.
So for our first test,
well, we wanted to throw one
in the forge but...
It's snowing really
hard outside right now.
So we're going to stick with
the indoor experiments today,
and then move
forward from there.
So first off,
while I have heard
that these lamps can absorb
moisture from the atmosphere,
I want to find out
whether or not they can melt.
Some people say they can't,
some people say they can.
Let's put it to the test.
So for these videos,
we don't need the base,
we're just kind of
taking them apart,
and I am very disappointed
because It's a lot easier
than I wanted it to be.
But it's good for our purpose is.
[Music]
Perfect.
That's a very
large chunk of salt.
So for one of our first
stress test here,
I have heard it said
that you cannot melt
or dissolve one of these lamps.
I don't know
if that's true,
and I want to find out.
So the first thing
that we're going to do is run
one of these under some water
on the time-lapse.
See what happens.
We're also going to put one
in a pot of boiling water
on the stove,
see if it dissolves.
All right.
So we've got everything set up
for our time-lapse.
Sorry about the dirty dishes,
but we want to see just
how long it takes to erode
away one of these salt lamps.
[Music]
Stress test number one,
can you erode a Himalayan
salt lamp with water?
Yes.
So we were playing with glass
on the table earlier,
so I'm hoping this is just salt.
Yeah, that's salt.
Okay.
All right, stress
test number two.
So we have seen
that you can erode away one
of these salt lamps
with just using tap water.
So we've actually got a little
set up here on the stove.
So this is going to be slightly
submerged in boiling water,
and while I do believe
that's just going
to dissolve it,
I'm curious to see
what the steam will do.
I want to see
if that's actually going
to help erode and dissolve
the outside of it as well.
[Music]
We've definitely
made a mess.
So the salt itself seems
like it's mostly been fine
from the steam.
Like I was expecting it to get
that same glassy outside
that we were getting on the one
that had the water running
over it and eroding it away.
Instead, what we've
gotten is the water
itself is turned almost opaque,
and it splattered
salt everywhere,
like the pot is just coated
in a powdery salt,
and I'm very curious.
I do think it's lost some
of its volume here.
So I'm going to try
and pick it up.
I want to know just
how much of it sunk
through the grating.
That's kind of hot to the touch.
Not too--
It's not too bad,
but I'm putting
on different glove.
[Music]
All right.
Time lapse is definitely
going to show that better,
because we lost about half
of its volume there.
I was not expecting that.
But it is not nearly
as smooth as it was
when we eroded
the other one away.
This is so very very rough,
course, almost the same
as it is on the other side.
Not nearly as effective as I
thought it was going to be,
especially compared
to the eroding.
Can you dissolve
a salt lamp using steam?
Yes, but it would probably
take a very long time.
So comparatively,
running it under water
versus simply allowing the steam
to do the work for you,
this one's going to survive,
that one, not so much.
All right.
So we've tried eroding one
of our salt lamps.
We've tried dissolving one,
and now, we want
to try melting one.
But to do that,
we're going to need
a lot more heat.
All right guys,
so we've made it up to the Dome.
We've already eroded
one salt lamp.
We've tried to dissolve another.
So for our final one,
we're going to melt it.
So we got this thing.
This is an extra large crucible
that just so happens to hold
our salt lamp perfectly.
So, let's drop it in,
see what happens.
[Music]
Sure, that's gonna work.
It's very cold here, guys.
[Music]
All right, so it's been
about 10 minutes,
and we've actually had
this on time lapse.
But I'm not sure
if we're actually going
to get the ambient heat
in our forge to be warm enough
to actually melt the salt.
So what we're going to do
is put the lid on now.
Hopefully, leave it
for a little while,
and when we come back,
it should be melted?
[Music]
All right, so I just
checked on this,
and I think we actually managed
to do this, guys.
It's been about
an hour and a half,
which is not as long as we
were expecting this to take.
We have successfully melted
an entire Himalayan salt lamp.
Oh wow!
So I was not expecting
it to have that much
of volume left over.
[Music]
Whoop.
Yep, and it's on fire.
I lit a stick on fire
with molten salt.
That's just cool.
It's actually leaking
out over the side.
There is so much more to that
than I thought there was.
Well, I was going to try
and take it out
and pour it into something.
But with how much there is here,
and with the size
of that crucible,
it's not really going to be safe
for me to try and lift
that up and transport it.
So we're going to let
it sit there and cool down,
see what it looks like ince
it's actually solidified again.
Or we can actually get our tongs
around it safely, transport it,
and dump it out.
That's really cool.
Like I know I don't want
to touch that,
but I actually really
want to touch that.
[Music]
So, we left this about
30 minutes to try
and let it harden.
It hasn't really cool that much.
It's still radiating
a ton of heat.
And I'm not sure
if it's solid yet.
So the surface
is no longer molten.
Now, I don't trust
that to be the case
all the way through it,
but we're still going
to try and get that out.
[Music]
That is a giant crucible
just full of salt.
And the surface
isn't pink anymore.
We're definitely gonna have
to reheat this crucible to get
the salt out at a later date,
but it's going to stay
like that for now.
So, can you erode
salt lamp away with water?
Yes, you can.
Can you dissolve it?
Not as well,
but you can still do that, too.
Can you melt it?
Absolutely, and that was
actually a lot faster
than we were expecting it to be.
That's pretty cool.
Well, I am kind of sad
that Veritasium proved
that you can't actually get
negative ions from heating
up a salt lamp,
because I think I win
the award for most
heated up salt lamp ever.
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top will take
you to our latest video,
and that box of the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Don't forget to hit this bomb
so you subscribe to the club,
and never miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.